charcoal is big business in Bamako the
capital of Mali almost everybody needs
charcoal to cook with and the population
is growing my muna trowel ray is a
charcoal merchant she's doing well but
her very success is becoming a source of
concern the Commerce awesome there are
fewer and fewer trees that's scary if
you go out of town you will see what I
mean an Australian agronomist with the
NGO World Vision
Tony Ronaldo has developed a method of
countering the deforestation that
affects large parts of Africa his work
won him the Right Livelihood award also
known as the alternative Nobel Prize as
land is cleared of the vegetation the
land gradually degrades and becomes less
and less productive this list can be
grown on at less profit can be made from
it and people become more desperate so
there is a very strong link between
conflict and land degradation and also
between migration and land degradation
my muna trial ray tells Reynaldo that
she now has to get her charcoal from a
hundred and sixty kilometers away
because source is closer to Bamako have
dried up it's a similar situation in and
around many of Africa's big cities the
disappearance of forests and degradation
of the land is a huge problem
how do we tackle it well fortunately
through the farmer managed natural
regeneration through the regeneration of
trees and landscapes there's a very low
cost rapid and scalable method to
reverse that degradation in the 1980s
ronaldo discovered that in many places
there are intact underground networks of
roots struggling to grow and at pruning
shoots can help trees and bushes
flourish World Vision is now promoting
the FMN our technique in 24 countries
around the world in y america in
northern Ghana Samuel Bunton was among
the first farmers to adopt it a decade
ago
you guys it has changed so much in my
village we used to have to drive our
cattle long distances to graze thieves
could steal them but now they can graze
nearby but there's still a lot to do
the villagers regularly go out and work
on reviving areas of degraded land
applying Renaldo's technique and trim
new shoots growing out of old stumps
farmer managed natural regeneration
isn't complicated it involves targeted
pruning and protecting of new growth
still it's very effective these saplings
will hopefully grow into tall trees we
cut some shoots but leave the bigger
ones just one or two what we cut away we
use as firewood the key advantage over
planting new trees is that the roots are
already there and reach deep into the
soil so even if it rarely rains they can
tap into the groundwater
trees can also raise the water table
release moisture into the air and
fertilize the soil when their leaves
fall and decompose as conditions
improved Samuel bunting was able to
increase his herd it has helped a lot
life used to be much harder but now
things are different
we have a proper income we can look
after our families pay for health
insurance and school fees and everybody
has enough to eat Enya Marika 82
hectares of land have so far been
reforested but large stretches still
look like a desert degraded dryland
regions may have countless intact tree
root systems that could yet yield new
trees if they're properly tended Rinaldo
organizes conferences across Africa on
FMN are also in countries that are in
turmoil such as Mali he was recently in
Bamako Ronaldo has devoted his life to
restoring Africa's forests he says
regenerating local vegetation improves
the lives of millions and giving people
hope can help transform the political
landscape as well in many a country it
would transform the whole country
because it has that potential people to
be able to be self-sufficient on their
own land they're not going to be so
interested in in joining a fight
somewhere else that their families to
raise they have aspirations and how they
would like to lead their life cities
such as Bamako consume vast amounts of
natural resources even as they become
ever more scarce the restoration of
vegetation around cities and elsewhere
can improve people's quality of life and
perhaps reduce the potential for
violence and conflict